Si les ordinateurs quantiques ne seront pas adaptés pour résoudre
tous les problèmes, il existe quelques classes de problèmes
et cas d'usage potentiels où on s'attend
à ce que l'informatique quantique ait un impact.
Cela inclut la simulation, comme
la modélisation de processus et de systèmes qui se produisent dans
la nature, la recherche et l'optimisation
qui consiste à chercher la meilleure ou
la solution optimale dans une situation avec
de nombreuses réponses possibles, et les mathématiques
et le traitement de données à structure complexe
y compris des applications pour l'apprentissage automatique.
Les algorithmes quantiques adoptent une nouvelle approche pour
ces types de problèmes, en exploitant
les propriétés uniques de la physique quantique comme
la superposition, l'interférence et l'intrication.
Les ordinateurs classiques se retrouvent bloqués
à explorer certaines zones de l'espace computationnel
et ne peuvent donc pas trouver ces motifs.
Les ordinateurs quantiques sont équipés
de capacités supplémentaires ou de performances accrues
pour certains problèmes, grâce à leur nature quantique.
Pour bien comprendre le potentiel des ordinateurs quantiques,
il faut plonger dans la théorie de la complexité computationnelle,
une branche de l'informatique qui se concentre sur
la mesure et la comparaison de l'effort computationnel nécessaire
pour résoudre différents types de problèmes.
Cela fournit un cadre utile
pour décrire différentes accélérations
et classes de problèmes rencontrés en
informatique.